what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with Invincible Iron Man and
Riri Williams is about to get smacked
around and not even by a little bit of
course this opens up with Ruby Williams
showing up at the hellfire club now for
those of the guys who were just joining
us in the Iron Man Comics yes in the
larger fall of X event Sentinels orcus
that huge organization is hunting down
mutants everywhere that they can find
them Tony Stark is one of the very few
Avengers if we're being honest that's
avidly working against the forces of
orcus and trying to help the mutant
population but he's also got his own
thing going on right his own struggles
and issues and so on but he's married to
Emma Frost quote unquote Miss Hazel who
basically wears an inhibitor ring so the
Sentinels won't realize she's a mutant
and Wilson fist the kingpen is kind of
like the public face of the hellfire
club so he's the guy that is more or
less keeping those mutants operating
within the hellfire club essentially
safe from orcus but what ends up going
on here is that when Riri Williams shows
up one of the things to remember is she
has the 10 Ring of the mandrin she's had
them for quite some time and when Miss
Hazel shows up Riri Williams does not
know that Hazel is actually Emma Frost
so she tries to use the telepathic
ability from the Mandarin's rings to
overpower Hazel and then say like take
me to Iron Man but as we learned from
the original fall of X event the core
X-Men themselves had what was called the
Red Triangle instilled in their brains
in effect it was a safety measure
created by Xavier so that even if all
the other mutants are somehow subdued or
captured by telepathy that the core
X-Men would not be right that's why Emma
Frost has these words resist that come
out as a literal triangle the issue is
that her inhibitor ring falls off and
then her telepathic powers emerge and
she immediately snatches up rby Williams
mind and brings it into the mindscape
and that's when rby Williams realizes
what's going on that is actually Emma
Frost here's the funny thing about this
Ruby Williams is too dumb to realize
Emma Frost is not to be trifled with
she's an Omega Level telepath man she
could have this girl just walking around
like a cat for the rest of her life
eating cat food that's just the kind of
power that she has so the two of them
actually end up getting into like a kind
of fight what's really cool here is Emma
Frost has like these brass knuckles as
say Hellfire it's like that scene from
Chappelle Show right like what is it
Charlie Murphy's True Hollywood stories
when Rick James punched him in the face
and he's got to rain the says Unity that
was amazing but I'm just saying this is
crazy because it kind of breaks down
into a fight between the two but while
it does look like ruy Williams is
essentially holding her own have no
Illusions this is Emma Frost pulling her
punches right this is Emma Frost just
like taking it lightly on this girl
because what's crazy is like literally
Ry Williams responds and she's like are
you kidding me you're the White Queen
wanted for murder and now you're
suddenly married to Tony Stark and the
response of Emma is excuse me Tony gets
to be married to one of my aliases now
how is it that this ring of yours grants
you telepathic Powers because Emma Frost
is not overly familiar with the rings of
the mandrain and what they do is they
kind of provide people an artificial
ability to use these varing Powers
manipulate fire and so on and so forth
and that's one of the things that Emma
Frost had picked up on that when it came
to Ruby Williams using telepathy she was
not a true telepath she was simply just
enhanced now the reason why that matters
so much and why that so incredibly
important is a true telepath is a person
that has been using telepathy for really
most of their life ever since they're
adolesence presumably when their power
is first manifested likely during
puberty or somewhere around that time a
person who's enhanced artificially
gained the power of telepathy meaning
they may have the ability to control it
but nowhere near the same level of
nuance as someone who is a true telepath
because a person who's enhanced in this
case Ruby Williams she can just take the
ring off and that power of telepathy is
gone she doesn't have to spend years and
years of her life honing her abilities
learning how to keep other people's
voices out of her head learning how to
put her voice into other people's heads
just the total Nuance of it right like
Ruby Williams doesn't have that and so
while this kind of conflict is breaking
out you switch back to Tony Stark and
and Kingpin who are just kind of talking
and then suddenly the detectors go off
that say like mutant detected one of the
things Tony Stark says or really uh
Wilson fist says is that orcus offered
to install the mutant detector and
declining the offer would have appeared
suspicious that if Wilson Fisk
especially coming out of what is it
Devil's Reign that storyline where he
kind of quote unquote went to war
against like the superhero Community if
he's really as steadfastly against
mutants as he publicly says he is then
why would he turn down the assistance of
orcus to detect mutants wherever they
need to be found it's a smart move and
so again what ends up happening is that
when a giant Sentinel shows up here here
Wilson Fisk bashes his face in and then
tells him an assassin the one called
Mystique just broke in and tried to take
me out it's a really good way to try to
subvert the Sentinels themselves but one
of the things to know and we covered
this during like Days of Future Past and
any of the stories that deal with
Sentinels they're not like human beings
you can't rationalize with them you
can't reason with them you can't trick
them or anything along those lines
unless you have the ability to either
Dodge their sensors or somehow interfere
with the inner workings of their
programming they will come for you and
they will come for you with ruthless
aggression that's what made dve of
future pass so bad right it wasn't that
there was some kind of all powerful Uber
Sentinels that existed out there like in
the movie no no no no there were just so
many of them right it was a war of
attrition hundreds of thousands if not
millions of Sentinels patrolling the
United States at all times right it was
a crazy situation and so even Emma Frost
starts to realize this because remember
given her level of telepathy yes she can
fight Ruby Williams in the mindscape but
she can also be aware of what's going on
out there in the real world that's how
capable she is and she's like the
Sentinels are going to be upon us and if
you insist on continuing this fight we
can do one in one of orc's labor camps
and so Ruby Williams tries to go back on
the assault only to be slapped around
again by Emma Frost and that's when she
snaps back to reality and then her and
ruy Williams join Iron Man in this
attack against a sentinel now here's the
cool thing about this right this ending
was something I never saw coming not in
a million years right Emma Frost of
course you end up with a fast ball
special which initially started out as a
Colossus and wolver rain move for those
of you guys who are unfamiliar literally
it was just Colossus throwing wolver
rain it's one of the most simple but
iconic movements in Marvel Comics and
it's kind of the same thing here right
ruy Williams throws Emma Frost at the
Sentinel Emma Frost takes on her Diamond
form and manages to punch this thing but
at the end of the day the concern is not
this Sentinel the concern is that the
Sentinel will tell orcus and everybody
else what's going on because remember
the information that these Sentinels
have are being sent back to orcus at
regular intervals so if they do not stop
this thing before the information is
sent back they're going to be met with a
mountain of Sentinels and so what goes
on here is that when Iron Man says I
can't crack this armor in the stealth
suit iron har what have you got from the
Rings the response of Ruby Williams is
she says I think I have something on
board that's better than the Mandarin
Rings I've got that special order you
asked me for Tony and when she uses it
it shrinks The Sentinel down she brought
pin particles right Iron Man requested
pin particles and it's such a genius
thing to do right you don't see this
very often right like it's such a just
genius strategy there's this gigantic
sign on this out there use pin particles
shrink it down and then smash it right
step on it this thing's virtually
useless it's just a machine that's
really it now this seems to ignore all
the issues with density and all that
kind of stuff but nonetheless right like
they managed to take this thing down
because one of the things to know about
pen particles just because the senal is
shrunken down does not mean that it's
weaker than it's historically been
before it's just as strong it's just
really small so by all standards of
measurement it should presumably be able
to still hold its own in a fight but
whatever comic books who cares so once
this thing is destroyed everything is
more or less kind of sorted out but
here's the cool thing right here's the
really cool thing about this Wilson Fisk
plays the public
to the press and the whole nine yards
right he says I'm grateful for our
emergency responders and for the Stark
Sentinels of course without them the
mutant who attacked me might have
succeeded in more than the property
damage to my home right so he's kind of
able to lead the public off the trail to
the fact that like Emma Frost was
actually here now of course Riri
Williams still has some of these pin
particles but what Stark tells Riri is I
need you to look at something that I've
been working on and I need you to build
something as well right what he says is
he asks her what do you think right and
she says the design work is impeccable
and he says yes I know that's not what
I'm asking can you build these ships and
she asked how much mysterium and where
on Earth will it be secretive or safe
enough and he says nowhere on Earth is
safe enough I need you to go up there
and he says but you have to be sure that
you can get it done and he even goes so
far as to tell her the lives of every
everybody on this planet depend on you
successfully fabricating those designs
now here's the kicker it'd be very easy
for us to assume that she's going to
Mars right she's going to orocco she's
heading up there to basically work with
what are believed to be the surviving
mutants that are up there because
remember Tony Stark doesn't know what's
happening on oraco storm and the whole
Genesis war and all that stuff they have
no idea what's taking place but that
doesn't seem to be where she's going he
simply says when you get there ask for
rri it looks like he's sending her to n
daver right to the dwarves the guys who
craft and build incredible weapons arms
and Armament right now here's the kicker
about this we've only seen one instance
before where something like this was
done and that was during fear itself
that's when Iron Man built that armor at
least those suits of armor for various
people that were imbued with portions of
the Odin Force right so again it's cool
who knows how all this is going to look
but in essence it's them going up or at
least Ruby Williams going up using the
mysterium that's being provided to her
that Tony Stark isn't using for his Iron
Man suit and then in turn building up
these new ships and whatnot that can be
presumably used in the war against orcus
that are based on mysterium and keep in
mind mysterium is equally capable and
durable to adamantium not true
adamantium not the stuff bonded to
Wolverine skeleton but the next step
down right the stuff that Ultron
historically used so it's cool and it's
really exciting but in the next video we
will at least it looks like finally get
Iron Man in his mysterium suit which I
am hyped about but with that being said
guys we're going to bring this to an end
if you guys need to get caught up on the
Iron Man comics and what's going on
right now make sure you click this link
to the playlist and I will catch you all
later peace